le pido un poco de contexto sobre Por
qué se toma ahora la decisión de
readmitir a Siria en la liga árabe
qué tal Muchas gracias por la invitación
como eventos más cercanos a este suceso
podríamos considerar el terremoto que se
produjo en el mes de febrero
entre Turquía y Siria que demandó una
respuesta
regional muy acelerada muy muy pronta
Estados Unidos levantó sanciones para
que la asistencia humanitaria pudiese
tener lugar y como consecuencia de hecho
se dio justamente una una respuesta
bastante mancomunada entre los países
del Mundo árabe para poder intervenir y
enviar ayuda al mismo tiempo se dio muy
recientemente un acuerdo patrocinado por
china entre Arabia Saudita y la
República islámica de Irán ambos países
con intereses a niveles geopolítico
económico muy fuertes en la región
particularmente Irán en Siria ya que ha
ayudado a avanzar a las al presidente
sirio proceso de reconstrucción
digamos soberano en los territorios
controlados por grupos rebeldes por el
estado islámico junto con Rusia pero
bien justamente este hecho el acuerdo a
también propiciado las condiciones para
que
dentro del mundo ar dentro del Golfo la
región del levante y también norte de
África se genera entonces la percepción
de que ya la comunidad internacional no
va a tomar cartas en el asunto de manera
eficiente que la intervención de Estados
Unidos como potencia global tampoco ha
sido exitosa es más La retirada
progresiva y decisiva de Estados Unidos
en la región ya prácticamente convence
al mundo árabe de que son esos los que
tienen que tomar cartas en el asunto
Porque además tienen que resolver la
situación de la cantidad inmensa de
refugiados sirios que han recibido en
los últimos 12 años por lo tanto desde
Jordania por ejemplo que se ha promovido
esta iniciativa tan fuerte de llevar a
tratar de reunir a los ministros de
exteriores y a los gobernantes de de los
miembros de la liga árabe se han
Entonces
sugerido se ha invitado a reconsiderar
la la reincorporación de Siria lo que No
necesariamente se traduce en que la
situación ya esté resuelta sino en ver
esto como Otra condición más de
posibilidad para que de aquí en adelante
se pueda avanzar en cierto proceso de
recomposición para este país partido
claro le pregunto precisamente para por
estos avances que se esperan no Qué
efectos en particular es desea la liga
árabe que está reincorporación de Siria
a la organización tengan tanto para el
propio país para Siria como para la
región
bueno por un lado hay que destacar que
que exista consenso para que Siria sea
reincorporada en la liga árabe no quiere
decir que todos los países estén tan de
acuerdo en cuanto a qué tan profundo ir
con con este gesto ni tampoco que esto
es una convalidación de vallar a Lázaro
como presidente legítimo pero sí es
digamos lo que se busca como efectos más
notables a un corto mediano plazo es
tratar de lograr cierta repatriación
progresiva seguramente lenta de
refugiados que retornen entonces a Siria
no están las condiciones para ellos
realmente porque los enfrentamientos en
país siguen existiendo y porque tampoco
ha habido institucionalmente un proceso
de paz de Reconciliación entre las
partes pero ese es un punto otro tanto
es que Siria y la presencia en Siria de
Irán constituye un factor de
preocupación en general porque esto
lleva a una atención
consiguiente con el estado de Israel
entonces de ese escalar posiblemente el
conflicto en Siria sea también una
manera de de digamos frenar un poco los
ataques selectivos que tienen lugar en
ese país por parte de lectores Israel
contra objetivos iraníes o de gisbolá y
otro tanto es que Siria se ha convertido
en una fuente digamos de
narcotráfico en los últimos años
cuestión que impacta también seguramente
dentro de las poblaciones de países
vecinos como Jordania que seas uno de
los principales promotores de esta
reincorporación de Siria la liga árabe
entonces también que todos los digamos
los miembros de esta de este organismo
internacional puedan velar puedan
monitorear un poco qué es lo que ocurre
en Siria y con cierto aval desde digamos
el plano doméstico en Siria para que eso
ocurra a lo mejor brinda un escenario
donde también se pueda poner freno por
ejemplo a esto un tema del cual se habla
bastante poco pero el narcotráfico
impacta bastante y preocupa
particularmente los gobiernos de Ciudad
de Jordania y de Arabia Saudita uno de
los pesos pesados de la región